okay hey how you doing man - Chung great
to meet you shoot it works how long you
been doing it five years I think how
long you've been doing this one thing
like 14 years with THC in six months a
year yeah okay and I study how to
basically make weed wine oh yeah you hit
it we won so tell the people what weed
one is about a year ago we decided well
what if we make the wine and then remove
just the alcohol and replace it with THC
and that's possible yeah we did it
you can win one without alcohol yeah
thank y'all come up with everything well
let me see what you got going on tell me
about these three particular brands you
have this is I started this winery in
2013 and I put my moustache on the
bottle no I did we sold that whoa
[Music]
I'm pretty high
I think I'll go home now
and if the bottle glows in the dark - I
just thought those oh you got that
marketing thing and this guy called
Sunday Funday
Sunday Funday yeah we made the pineapple
on it scratch and sniff just for fun I
[Applause]
used to not be and we do so tell people
it was your very hands on with this
stuff that's what it's gonna that's why
I was gonna work for you yeah you found
your passion Epson and I talk about it
all the time on this show that once you
look is zero in on your passion yeah it
makes everything else a little bit easy
well I mean you oughta look at this this
is very nice
yeah it's look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
listen these two are real ones
why don't one that's like traditional
it's got alcohol in it is that red or
white is red sera sera
that's good that's got a refund yeah how
much tea a season I borrow this right
now it's dosed just like a glass of wine
like the intoxicating effects are the
same like a glass of wine won't get you
drunk
but you'll catch a little buzz yeah and
that's five milligrams of glass but it's
fast-acting how much would you say that
we went for it's out the door it's 75
bucks a bottle that's not bad
rubble Coast rubble Coast right a little
bit of rubble Coast rubble coats that
ain't bad
it's hard to make wine without alcohol
or it's hard to make wine and then
remove the alcohol so yeah oh yeah and
we've got something for you too Wow
yes my brother here we just had any
human big old bottle down I put somebody
in there and it's plague oh thank you
for looking out cheerily oh she did she